foreign
let's go to uh Megan in Spring Hill
Kansas my favorite state what's up Megan
hello it's good to talk to you Dr John
it's good to talk to you how are you
I'm good how is the land of uh waving
grain
well I will tell you it's great out here
but but you as well as the Ramsey team I
guess we're we're probably just not good
enough for you because you guys never
come back to Kansas City
dude Kansas dis here's the thing I put
up some internet post recently where I
was like
do whatever you got to do to change your
life like and sell stuff
um you know have hard conversations move
to Kansas if you have to and the
internet took that and they said it was
like a Diss and it's not I think you can
I've got family in Kansas and you can
have a killer life there for one one
millionth of the price of having
A hurried psychotic life in Manhattans
anyway I'm all Kansas I'm gonna
intentionally plan an event there in the
coming months is that cool
uh that would be great I'll be there
you'll come okay well uh in fact we'll
get your info and we'll hook you up
whenever we make it happen okay oh
oh we're gonna do this we're gonna party
in Kansas it's gonna be mine yeah my uh
apology tour to Kansas all right so
that's not what you called what's up
um so I was calling um hopefully this is
one of your lighter calls I am calling
to ask how can I control my control
issues
kind of
um I guess a longer explanation
um kind of a
a wide range of answers there but I feel
like it has gotten a lot worse since
I've had kids I have two girls a four
year old and a six month old and I just
feel like every single thing in my in
our life in our family's life I have to
control I need like I control our
schedule in our calendar and
um so my husband travels for work he's
one of those railroaders I heard on one
of your podcasts before um yes so you I
know that you know all about that life
he's home like one day a week
um if we're lucky we get just over 24
hours with him but
um so like even on that one day a week
it's like I don't
I don't just like take a step back and
like relax and ah okay he's here like
we're a family we can just relax on this
say no way it's like oh by the way this
day is scheduled minute by minute even
though your hearings are only day with
you
um and like even down to things such as
when he is home I find myself like I
have to drive the car because I don't
know which route you're gonna take and
I'm not gonna like that or
um just anything that we do have planned
I need to know like the who the when the
where the why the how behind it all I
just feel like I need to be in control
of absolutely everything which leaves no
like room for just breathing and just
letting life happen and I will tell you
my husband's completely opposite he's
the kind of guy that says um I think
there's a quote that's like life happens
when you're too busy planning for it
something like that so how do I you know
why he can say that
because he's with you
I was gonna say because I control
everything that's right and my guess is
he's somebody in his family possibly his
mom did the same thing or it was very
similar
um yeah but he can do that that's my
attitude come what may dude let's figure
it out because I have a wife that takes
care of all the crap you know what I
mean and so that's that's the definition
of privilege just to be like what why
are you worried about that well somebody
has to feed the kids right so yeah I
don't want you to feel insane
um this started a long long time ago
when did it start
um so my only guess is when I was four
my dad died in a car accident so very um
unexpectedly okay I just smiled
um not because your dad passed away so I
want people watching this on YouTube and
I'd be like this guy's got no soul I'm
smiling because the way you framed it
was like I I've done some deep digging
and I dropped a couple of big gulps
walking out of a supermarket once and
you're you're like I I went looking and
um the only thing I can come up with is
my dad died of course yeah I mean that's
the only thing I can
[Music]
I am completely making this up and you
and I can spend three or four hours
together just hanging out in Kansas and
we can we could go deeper okay my guess
is
when your dad passes away
that's huge especially when you're four
but what's equally if not more
um
maddening insane besides the grief and
loss your whole world is over at that
point and you're gonna have to have a
new world
but it's the adults in your life whose
worlds also explode
yes and my guess is was your mom in the
scene back then
um
no no no no was your mom how did she
handle this
um
I mean looking back I
we're not a family that shares our
emotions period so I remember we went to
counseling I think
um I mean gosh looking back I don't
honestly remember I know that my sister
went
separately she was seven years old at
the time and then we all went together I
don't think that I went all by myself
but I I could totally be wrong on that
um so nobody went to counseling I don't
really remember talking much about it
other than in counseling um right so
listen so repressed uh repressed that
sounds so dramatic
you've been parenting yourself since you
were four years old
and four-year-olds don't have the
capacity for words like sad they don't
have words like heartbroken like what
what just our whole world is in ashes
why why does Mom keep disappearing
yeah mom is radioactive but she won't
tell me she doesn't have the words to
say and it's not I'm not begging on mom
mom didn't have a skill set either her
whole world exploded but
mom didn't know that the greatest gift
she could give me as a four-year-old was
to hug me so tight and say I miss Daddy
so much
yeah because you miss Daddy too and you
would have not been more depressed you
would have felt less insane
okay and so your four-year-old body has
been grabbing for control because that's
all it had and you've been grabbing it
for a long time and how old are your
kids
they're six months and four or six month
old and a four-year-old
your body has a pin
in four years old
and it would not surprise me if you have
not been on an escalating control uh
your grip has been tightening on your
world over the past six to nine to ten
months is that fair
yep
your body is gearing up for this moment
when everything explodes again
yep it remembers this and you're married
to a railroad guy yeah I know right so a
lot of this and I do talk about that I
know but like but that a lot of the
control the world of railroaders is not
set up for human existence
yeah it's set up to extrapolate the last
ounce of soul out of somebody in
exchange for money in the future a good
retirement that's what that job is for
yeah exactly not designed to have a
family to be a Cornerstone of a
community to eat to have any sort of
Health right any job that says this is
gonna suck so bad I'll give your wife a
full retirement is already saying up
front we don't care about you that's a
whole other podcast though right so
that's the world you're in and so your
control needs are are real
somebody's got to feed those kids and
even when your husband's off you know
this he's a zombie
and he has to this isn't like a he's got
he's got to do something to relax too
right he's got to have hobbies and be
able to go outside and move around
otherwise he'll just die
um yeah so there's two things going on
here and this is just a quick flyby
right because this is something you and
I can spend more time with
yeah
at some point you're gonna have to feel
those feelings you've never felt
I feel like I don't know how to go about
that because I I listen to you for since
day one and I've heard you say um you
know like write your feelings Journal
your feelings feel your feelings and
I've tried to journal them but honestly
after like one or two feelings or
thoughts I just I'm like okay yep I'm
fine and then it doesn't come for
I don't know it's a very long period
that's fantastic here's where I start
is I identify the behavior that is that
is maladaptive I identified the behavior
in my life that is not serving me or the
people I love very well
okay for me it's grabbing food for you
it's when you you start getting more
controlly and more angsty and more
right
yep that's the moment that you sit down
and write your feelings down
if you just Bebop in on a normal
Saturday morning dude your body's better
than that it's it's shove that crap so
far down under so many layers of
performance and joy and smiles and
dancing and by the way you don't have to
have some big cathartic you don't have
to replay the wreck none of that kind of
stuff
okay it's it's not that it's it's simply
this
your husband comes home and he's like
hey we're all going to dinner tonight
and you instantly your heart rate goes
up yep it's I have a plan and we're
eating here I've been thawing meat since
four o'clock and you just Walt it yeah
that right there is what we're gonna
work on okay so we're gonna go in our
bedroom for five minutes after he just
announces that and you're gonna talk to
him ahead of time and say I'm trying to
learn about my body
and you're going to ask yourself this
one question what is my body trying to
protect me from
and just answer that question
and probably it's just gonna it's gonna
wind all the way down to
we control about nothing in this world
yes about nothing
right
yes and you know more than anybody in
the world
that we can have all the safety
protocols and do all the right things
and some drunk driver is going to hit us
and it's all over
yeah but he was actually he was the
drunk driver but he was okay or somebody
we love is gonna go do something stupid
and get themselves killed yes right
which I actually didn't learn until that
he was intoxicated until geez Louise
um less than 15 years ago which tells me
you've got a family culture of Secrets
and secrets destroy people
yeah from the inside out my guess is you
might have passed that along I brought
that to your marriage
and it might not be Secrets if you're
seeing somebody else although it might
but it's probably secrets of
um how angry and raged out you get at
the railroad how frustrated you are with
your husband being gone all the time and
you love him and want to support him but
God I wish I had a regular husband at a
regular job in a regular life like all
and you bottle those things up and you
keep them and keep them and keep them in
the way your body has chosen to handle
that sort of
um compression is through control mine
is through eating and distraction
my wife is through control
um some of my friends are through
alcohol or weed some of my friends are
from flirting and hanging out with
people they're not married to right so
it's all across the board everybody
deals some is it's workaholism they just
work and work and work and try to outrun
it
it's sitting down and saying okay this
is what I'm feeling right now
okay and being able to say okay I had
plans
I do want to go out actually
let's do it or like my wife will do to
me she'll say
I would love to go out
but it's not in our budget we didn't
budget for it I do have this food set
and I don't want to waste it and I
really would like I need a quiet night
at home
and I say great and that's different
than control
that's being able to express your needs
which comes after being able to feel
stuff does that make sense
it does yes thank you so here's what I
want you to consciously think of when
you start tightening up
consciously this is a the practice pull
your shoulders down as low as they'll go
and open your hands because almost
always your hands will clinch up yeah
open your hands and then go need five
and go in your room and write it down my
guess is you may end up not needing to
talk to somebody not to promise not to
go process the trauma from that long ago
but my guess is y'all are gonna have to
learn new skills on how to be married
that you didn't get growing up
yeah
is that fair
do you want your husband to quit his job
he won't he will not and the thing is
you know he will be like oh yeah I'm
home this week and he'll be in time for
a week and they'll be like oh by the way
next week I have to go just two hours
away which is for the railroad is right
down the street I'm like oh of course
you do because you know you got to be
home for one week and you got to be
here's here let me say do you want him
to quit his job
foreign
[Music]
yeah okay hey here's the thing
for so long you haven't said what you
need because you couldn't because it
didn't matter
yeah and you've got to get to a place
where you're able to say here's what I
need
and it might not be I need you to quit
your job but it might be I need my
husband
yeah I need my friend I need my lover I
need my co-parent and this job is in the
way of that
yes otherwise
you're going to end up in a big pile of
resentment
yeah we're on our way you are and
somebody at Whole Foods is going to wink
at you or help you with a carton and
you're going to get their number and all
of a sudden you're gonna be Off to the
Races or he is going to realize that you
have a distance between the two of you
and he's going to text somebody right
see that's how that happens
let's back out of that thing you just
said I know I know Megan
you've got to back out of this thing and
say here's what I need
okay I need you and then we're gonna
backfill that and it's again it's a
skill to practice and I don't think
you've ever said your needs out loud
yeah is that true
that's true I mean maybe maybe starting
to now
um yeah but you wait too long if you
start announcing your needs on the back
end of a of a failed control attempt
it's War
M so if he comes out here's here's what
that sounds like um so if he comes home
and says
hey let's just forget it let's go out to
eat I'm taking everybody out to dinner
yeah and in your head you've been
preparing for a meal all day you know
that kid number one has been whining all
day and I'm not taking that one out in
public and this one's got the the
rockets diarrheas and I'm annoyed and
I'm
and he just comes home and announces
that right yes then you start seething
and you clinch your hands up and you
clinch your jaw up and you start you get
a little bit louder with the cabinets
and then he's like why are you so mad I
want to take you out to dinner because
he's really trying to help and you say
we us I've already got stuff started and
he's like I know I just want to be there
for you and then you snap
yeah I need you that's not needs that's
War
yeah the needs are the week before when
you say hey and this is this is what a
gift my wife gave me when you just Waltz
in and announce you're taking the family
out to dinner you just have inserted
yourself into an entire family ecosystem
that you are away from
yes that makes me feel X
yeah so if you want to go out to eat
would you text me as soon as you think
of it during the day and I can text you
back and say I've already got dinner
ready do you wanna you still want to go
you see what I'm saying we've had to
create a new algorithm and really at the
end of the day my goal was to help I was
trying to help her out and I learned the
best way to help her out is to ask her
what she needs and her best way to get
the help she needs is to be honest with
me about what she actually needs that's
totally different than me trying to save
the day see what I'm saying yeah
definitely and I can see that in our
our relationship as well
so no more war but all that starts with
is your control helping
no I think it I just try it it just like
grows yes like I get a little bit of
control here so I need to
control you know the next thing and then
the next thing the next thing and that's
nothing's actually under control
everything's really just on fire right
now yes but your grip is so tight that
you feel like you got it and you're
getting dragged behind a car pulling you
down the highway and you're like I got
this and everyone's like you clearly
don't have this right so yeah here's the
here's the um I say this a lot and I'll
end with this
the things that kept us safe and Alive
as a kid are the things that often are
disruptive to our adult lives
this worked for you because it had to
because mom went in a black hole of
grief and may have never come out
because y'all went to a couple of
counseling sessions and then you learned
really carefully really quickly that our
family keeps Secrets some things we
don't talk about
and you felt crazy and then that little
body that little girl said we're on our
own we got to control everything because
that's our path forward
and now you have your own little kids
and you realize you can't control
anything
you have your husband who works for a
disastrous industry in terms of how it
treats people
and you realize I've lost him too and
then you start thinking well here's what
I can control I can control that
relationship I can control this I can
control how organic the spinach is
whatever and you end up winding yourself
up in a straight jacket
you're worth a peaceful life
you're worth a marriage that works
you're worth not cheating on somebody
you're worth kids being able to laugh
you're worth walking through life with
Your Hands Held open because anything
else is an illusion
whoo let me know how that goes I want to
hear your progress on that Megan and uh
I'll keep our listeners notified thank
you so much for being brave